in the annals of a shy it is told how
the Valyrians of legend came to possess
dragons it is said that people so
ancient that they had no names first
came the Dragons in the shadow at the
heart of darkness a place that all
mortals even shadow binders fear the
people of the shadow brought the first
dragons to Valyria and taught the
Valyrians the art of magic showing them
how to tame the Dragons and bind them to
their will
though the Valyrians themselves claim
that they found the Dragons layering in
the 14 flames the version found in ash I
in some ways seems to fit reality better
the Valyrians were a simple folk for
many centuries before they came to
possess the power of dragons and there
is no explanation found for how
illyrians came to know magic if people
from the heart of darkness taught the
Valyrians
then it would explain how they went from
simple sheep herders to one of the most
formidable empires of all time in a
matter of years but the claims of the
ash ie are not all we have to support
the idea that dragons came from the
shadow in a game of Thrones bran is
shown a glimpse of the entire world for
just a moment including a shy he lifted
his eyes and saw clear across the Narrow
Sea to the Free Cities and the green
Dothraki sea and beyond to Vaes Dothrak
under its mountains to the fabled lands
of the Jade sea to a shy by the shadow
where dragons stirred beneath the
sunrise this seemed takes place near the
beginning of the game of Thrones while
Danny's dragons weren't born until the
very end
this indicates something very clearly
Danny's dragons weren't the cause of
magic returning to the world because
dragons were never extinct in the first
place Daenerys herself initially
suspects this to be true though she is
discouraged by her handmaidens she had
heard that the first dragons had came
from the east from the shadow lands
beyond - I and the islands of the Jade
Sea perhaps some were still living there
in realms strange and wild so who are
these people from the shadow who gave
the knowledge of dragons and how to use
them to the Valyrians that much is
unclear but there is a potential
connection between them and something on
the other side of the world though
master Theron had claimed that the sea
stone chair was built by the Deep Ones
the sea dwelling beings of legend
maester Curt suggested that the object
was left by visitors who came from
across the sunset sea but what lies
across the sunset sea if you look at a
map you can see that this place is where
all knowledge fails us we can only
speculate as to what secrets are hidden
there however the planet is round in a
game of Thrones during the same vision
that shows brand dragons stirring in a
Shai Moran crosses the curtain of light
at the end of the world and moves beyond
it to see the other side this means that
either another continent that has yet to
be discovered exists beyond the sunset
sea or simply it meets the other end of
essence that the visitors mr. Curt
speaks of we the people of the shadow
there is a question proposed by the
world of Ice and Fire but seeks answers
regarding the motives of these shadow
people yet if men in the shadows had
tamed the Dragons first why did they not
conquer as the Valyrians did the maester
here has submitted a fallacy a loaded
question making the false assumption
that these beings in the shadow must
have been wind it is in the heart of men
to rule and conquer however we know
nothing about these people of the shadow
perhaps they did not possess the desires
of men it is said that strange things
live in the shadow demons and twisted
beasts but these are all tales the true
nature of what lies in the shadow and
its heart is largely unknown in my video
on a Shai I explored the possibility
that reward himself could live in the
heart of the
at stag I the corpse city since
according to Miller Sondra shadows are
creatures of the light this could
justify why shadows covered this place
it would make sense for a being such as
real or a fire God to give the gift of
dragons fire made flesh to humanity
Milla saundra once said that real or
spoke to his chosen few in the language
of ash and cinder and twisting flame
that only a god could truly grasp could
it be that the Valyrians were given a
mission viral or but failed when they
grew too vain the bones of dragons can
be found in many places of the world but
it is said that the Valerians harnessed
and subjected them as no one else could
the Valyrians believed themselves to be
kin to dragons and even gods themselves
they enslaved an uncounted number of
people and none can say how many
perished in the Valyrian minds but it is
known that the number was so large that
it defies comprehension the death of
Valyria was fire and ash the 14 flames
erupted and split the earth beneath the
freehold allowing the ocean to rush in
the people of the Valyrian freehold
seemed to have been claimed by the wrath
of rail or the knowledge of shaping
black stone creating Valyrian steel and
taming dragons couldn't simply have
appeared out of nowhere especially for
sheep herders who would have largely
been uneducated apart from a shy Valyria
was the only place in the world where
the arcane arts were practiced so openly
and the similarities between the black
Valyrian stone on Dragonstone and the
black stone in which a Shai is built
from has been noted perhaps it is not a
coincidence that a Shai which lies so
closely to the shadow and valaria
which may have been influenced by
visitors from the shadow share certain
properties these people from the shadow
were likely servants of real or
HAP's human perhaps not we know there
are other sentient species in this world
the evidence for the deep ones is far
too great to be ignored and the
existence of the children and the Giants
is blatant these people from the shadows
spread this knowledge for a purpose and
though that purpose has been lost to
time the ramifications of what they did
have been felt for thousands of years
even currently centuries after the fall
of Valyria
Valerius destruction ended the time of
the dragons in Essos and the people of
the shadow vanished while we can
speculate as to exactly what happened
the truth is hidden beneath many aeons
of legend and lore